welcome to chess 4/9 aka the 2 o'clock
class the 1 o'clock class didn't meet
expectations because in one of the games
the both kids castle with their queen
and the king went through the Queen and
it was still the best game of the class
life by far
all right now today we're gonna look at
a game that I played several weeks ago
in your favorite City
exactly Atlanta there's no chess playing
in the class you have to watch there you
can go next door and play okay this is
chess class don't play chess all right
also face this way yeah okay at 2:30
you can either play chess when I'm done
lecturing or you'd go to the dentist you
know 2:30 - now you got it Wow I'm
shocked all right nice ok I could tell
he got it because he was smiling to show
his pearly whites all right so this game
was played against the 2100 and in fact
when I asked him what his name was he
said a 2100 so his first thing was a and
his last name was 2100 you know what his
name is now after this game his name
changed he's now a 2099 ok now I had the
black pieces and I have lots of funny
stories about this game okay first we
played my favorite opening Sicilian okay
and unlike a lot of people he played the
open Sicilian because he was a kid and
kids liked the open Sicilian okay
and when I have the black pieces and
it's a Sicilian this is usually the
position that I get this is called the
classical variation so named by John
none in this position there's two very
common moose for white at the
Grandmaster level
what are those common moves raise your
hand let's call on a random student
Arjun Bishop g5 is correct
this should be twos probably
the third most common mode so more
common the Bishop e2 Bishop g5 I agree
that's the rouser variation and the
other move which was a favorite of
Fischer also named after Fischer at some
point you Bishop e5 is a move probably
the fifth most common move Arjun which
move is that Bishop c4 okay
and I probably face Bishop g5 more often
but my opponent played Bishop c4 okay
and I used to play e6 and then I played
Queen b6 and now I play e6 again
confusing even myself
okay so I play D six and he played the
vellum yurevic attack which is where
white castles Queen side and if we go
back when Bobby Fischer played this O's
in he would Castle kingside
and then he would play for f4 f5
attacking the e6 pawn a million times
okay but the vellum yurevic attack is
probably more common now and that's
where white castles Queen side and tries
to checkmate black it's not very nice
and in fact I've had this position many
times and if you open a chest book or if
you go to a computer and say hey what's
the most common move here
the answer is Queen c7 Queen c7 gets off
the rooks file so the guy never takes
your queen and if you want to play b5
and checkmate your opponent b5 is risky
now why is b5 risky you the b5 line
is attacked multiple times that's
correct however there's a more dangerous
answer random students are Jim the
knight on c6 is hanging so you'd lose a
knight so if black plays Queen c7 you
fences night okay so that's the most
common move now in 1995 I was on an
airplane and we were flying from Detroit
to Los Angeles I was trying to figure
out which city was worse and more
dangerous I still haven't figured it out
anyway I'm the plane I had a hardcover
book that was written descriptive
notation okay and only my old reviewers
at home know a descriptive notation is
that's like instead of writing efore and
c5 you write pawn to King four and pawn
to Queen Bishop four right no talking
okay and I had a book that was written
in the 1970s by British chess players
talk about a misnomer okay if you ever
want to know what an oxymoron is
somebody say British chess players and
then go perfect okay in in the book when
I opened it up there was a diagram and
the diagram had the Queen on on King one
or as we would say ëi and I thought the
diagram had a typo like it was a mistake
the Queen should be on da but they made
the diagram ah and then I looked and the
last move was Queen da and I was like oh
so Queen EA is actually the move that
was played this was invented by your
favorite Grandmaster Alexandra Bally
offski if only you could see their faces
at home argent here to bali offski
you're my only hope
yeah maybe now there's a funny story
about ballet offski if you come to the
chess club and hear a strong grandmaster
you will definitely be recognized by the
front desk workers
okay and for the Sinquefield Cup ii sing
feel Cup I believe possibly the third we
had Maxime Vasya magrav and his second
was Alexander beli offski who was one of
the top ten players in the world for 20
years but now he's in his 60s now he's
not in Bali offski went to the front
desk and they said can we help you do
you want to join the club okay because
they
know who that is okay they also ask that
of Carlson on and on who are you okay
now some of the front desk workers know
Evalia ascii is but not really anyway
ballet ops he invented the move Queen e8
in 1973 and there's a very famous saying
in chess what's old and forgotten is
once new again what okay so if you do
something that was popular 3040 years
ago everybody forgot about it so now I
play it and they're like huh what's that
move and then I crushed them and this is
a good example
so I played Queen EA and my opponent was
like what
okay now Queen EA is a very interesting
move because the Queen on EA defends my
knight so now when I play b5 my nice
defended also when I play all these
moves my queen is defending da for pawn
which actually happens later and in some
positions white plays Queen aged five
and tries to checkmate me then sometimes
my Queen on EA can take his Queen when I
move by half block and that didn't
happen this game because my opponent was
too busy getting checkmated for him to
checkmate me he was like should I
checkmate my opponent or should I let
him checkmate me then he looked at the
notation sheet and saw my rating and saw
his rating and he did the right thing
okay so he made a mistake
almost every move now because he didn't
know them both Queen Hey now I gave
lectures on this before but you were all
asleep at the time the lectures were on
opposite side castling I Castle one way
and they Castle the other way then we
check meet each other then the class
goes yay it's not a boring endgame it's
checkmate okay and you'll see that this
game so normally white starts pushing
all of his King side pawns and tries to
checkmate me and I push all my Queen
side pawns and try to checkmate him and
at least half of that happen the other
half didn't happen so my opponent played
King v1 that doesn't really threaten my
king very much does it
dead ninth lady for and already I'm
threatening something notice if I take
his pawn he'll take my knight
so should I do that no but if I attack
his a knight and then his Knight moves
away that'll take his point yeah yeah so
he defended his fun okay and I developed
my bishop and he was like hmm if I make
a nothing move like here look at that
okay then I'll attack is nice and since
he played King b1 he can't put his
Knight there where can he put his knife
a for remember when I played Queen e8
defending a4 and you all laughed at me
now
I take his night he takes my night and I
got two guys on his night he's got one
guy defending it so I went and I did my
opponent lose a night like that no
because of his name a 2100 not an 1100
then he would have lost his night okay
so my opponent was like hmm this move
might win a piece I need a square for my
knight so he played Queen f2 now if I
attack his Knight he has a square for
his Knight
you see how that works okay now the last
few moves has my opponent been
checkmating me now as we say in India
he's doing Vishwanatha right yeah
exactly
very good okay so I took his Knight but
I had a good reason
in fact you told me the reason earlier
thank you you said if you play b5 the b5
pawn has attacked a lot that's right and
I wanted to play a5 a4 and win his
Bishop but if I play a 5 he'll take my
be pawn and I'll cry so I traded Knights
and then I played a 5 I don't think he's
taken my be pawn now right
you agree now I want to play a four next
move and his Bishop is trapped so what
did he do about it
you with the right answer that was the
right answer
he played pawn a three now if my queen
was on c7 which is the main behind the
Queen's on c7 that he could play a four
but he can't play a four here because I
have all these guys I have a lot of guys
on a four so he played a three and I
played B for attacking his night and we
traded and where did his knight go
what's the only safe square you E - that
was better than my answer because he has
to save squares a 2 + e 2 e 2 is ok but
he played a - the reason was he plays
Knight e 2 then the whole file is open
to his King so I would somehow get my
Queen to a 1 then he would get
checkmated so he blocked the a file with
Knight a - I wanted to get my Queen over
there but I can't jump over my bishop if
I was magnus carlsen I could but I'm not
that high rated yet so I was thinking
maybe I'll play Bishop a4 and then my
queen I'll go over there and this found
a big move but I attacked his Bishop and
he saw it and then I played Bishop e6
and now my Queen can go to a for later
pray I have a question who has a better
attack on the king Black has an attack
or White has an attack black is white
doing a lot of attacking now nothing
horrible okay now he didn't want me to
take his bishop and mess his pawns up so
he played Knight see one okay and I was
like wow my rook on FA that's doing a
good job attacking his King
no and I was thinking wow I could get a
lot of pieces on the a file like my
queen and my rock and then he wouldn't
be he wouldn't like that would he
so I played rook to 86 and I thought
I'll play Queen to AAA and then I'll
play rook a1 checkmate that seems good
for black right and if I don't do that
my queen could go somewhere else and
then my other work could go to a a with
the same idea so I played rook a sex he
traded bishops and now my work actually
is opposite his queen so he was worried
about Knight takes e4 did you see what
I'm saying okay so he played Queen e2
attacking my rook
Wow every move he makes is attacking my
King now I'm just kidding okay and I
played Queen a for defending my rook
what else does Queen a4 do yes yeah
Queen a1 checkmate my opponent since his
name was a 2100 didn't want to get
checkmated that's true
so what move did he make to stop Queen
a1 checkmate yeah that stops checkmate 1
c3 then I would probably play pawn d3
and then his name would be changing very
soon to a 2099 because I don't see how
you stopped me I guess you could take
this cuz my rook is c3 was Jesus okay so
b3 is good and taking is good everything
is good he actually stopped my Queen
from going to a1 by defending a1 Selena
Knight b3 did I play Queen a1 anyway no
that he would take it now kids like to
check their opponents so they would go
here then he would move away then they'd
be like oh oh ok so when your opponent
wants to run away
that means you don't want him to run
away think about that so if my opponents
King was on g1 I wouldn't really have an
attack against his king but if his King
is on b1 okay so I want to make sure he
never runs away okay now remember
earlier in the game I was complaining
that my rook was a little silly
so I played rook c8 and the reason I
played rook c8 was that if his King runs
away then he would have to cry a lot he
can't take my queen and if he takes my
ruck I have checkmate and not only is it
checkmate I used to have a shirt that
said Queen c2 exclamation mark as I put
that shirt on even though I had it when
I was 14 it would still fit so my
opponent didn't run his king away if my
opponent does nothing like here then I
check he makes the only legal move and
then I do that thing I just showed you
okay now my opponent didn't wanna lose
his Knight cuz he's a twenty-one hundred
but if he moves his knight somewhere
I'll play Queen a one me so what did he
do yeah the back that's exactly what he
did and he has two ways to do it and
Queen the d3 that he played the one you
said ripped to d3 all right so my rooks
doing a good job my queen and rook are
doing a good job over here is just sort
of chilling out I'm not really doing
anything over there okay so in the
Sicilian it's said many times that black
wants to make this move man can I make
this move now it's protected a million
times you d5 and usually you don't have
another pawn okay now a lot of kids cry
a lot like you and you're like I don't
like doubled pawns you
crying okay double pawns in the center
pretty good because then you can start
moving all your Center pawns yay
and this epon is really good is I
control d5 so d5 okay now I have a very
complicated plan which is too hard for
this class so no crying it's way too
hard for you at home maybe like if
Gustafson is watching maybe but he's a
German Grandmaster so okay means not not
a British Grandmaster even so okay so
let's play on nothing move for white now
I'm going to show you my plan attack is
Bishop he can't go back because
checkmate so he'll go somewhere else
let's go here on and then I was going to
play rook c3 let's say he takes my rock
and I take his pawn now if he plays King
here to run away then that would be
checkmate and if he doesn't play king b1
I'm going to play Queen here check and
then play the checkmate I don't really
see a good way for white to stop that
plan
I think White's King is in a lot of
trouble because his King can't really
escape my point on c3 is pretty good
okay so that was my plan my opponent
gets to move too so he played the move
Bishop to g5 okay and now he's putting
pressure on all my Center he's going to
take everything and if I play pawn here
that doesn't attack his bishop and he
probably figured if he trades pieces I
won't made him because there's no pieces
got enough pieces to make somebody okay
now Bishop g5 does something bad that I
teach at all of my classes Bishop g5
takes a piece that's protected many
times and it moves it in my territory
and unprotected what's protecting this
vishal nothing and he's opposing my
bishop the bishops are almost attacking
each other so that means of the five
night movie that I have one two three
four five they all attack his bishop
with a chest tactic called discovered
attack okay
now also I'm trying to checkmate my
opponent so I'd like to take the
checkmate and the discovered attack and
make them one tactic you never get to do
that unless it's in a book and it's a
puzzle book in your own games it never
works although it didn't work it's like
it's a lecture about it okay now you'll
remember when I'm checkmating my
opponent and my opponents running away
he gets to go to d2 if he had a pawn on
g2 I could have checkmated him a long
time ago Queen a to chat queen a 1 check
his king is trapped but his king can
escape via D to wonder what move I could
make which controls d2 who we think
about that you Knight takes e4 hey guess
what his King can't go to d2 anymore
wasn't that lucky well we didn't get to
that yet okay
now I've taken a pawn so I'm up a pawn
you agree if he takes my knight which
gives him d2 then I can take his Bishop
and then he doesn't have no one doesn't
in that gives that c1 so let's say he
takes my night and I take his Bishop I'm
not a big fan of his King I'm a big fan
of it but he's not
now I'm threatening Queen a to checkmate
and black is ahead material and I have
an attack does white have an attack on
my King now
okay so that would be really bad and if
I wanted to I could play editions good
because I like stangs ruins urgh I could
play Queen a to check and then play
Bishop takes g5 check
then he would have to cry a lot well I
think the only way to escape checkmate
is rookie 3 so then his King can escape
and then after here I had to give him a
lot of Kleenex because a lot of crying
right okay so he didn't play pawn takes
tonight but I'm up a pawn I'm
threatening me and his Bishop is
attacked twice so if his name was a 2600
he would resign here but his name was a
2100 so he fought on right and he played
Bishop takes he seven now when I was
thinking here hmm what should I do my
original thought was this this check for
King his king and queen takes takes
black stand to pieces but I don't see
how White's King gets out I'm
threatening Queen a 2 and then Queen a 1
so I was like wow I'm down to pieces but
his K looks really in trouble and then I
was like wait a minute
I don't have to sacrifice my knight I
have checkmate right here that I was
very pleased because I don't want to
calculate 20 moves ahead when I can
calculate two moves ahead
so after Knight takes e4 I knew he
couldn't play Bishop takes a seven but
he did anyway and then I was like oh boy
oh you quick cook the super slow slow
Queen a - can you see one and now notice
he can't go to D to remember so I play
Queen a1 now I was why I would take the
Queen and guy made it because then the
crowds like ei me but he gave up here
boom okay and now he resigned because
he's getting made now this could go an
electret opposite side castling because
i attacked with all of my pieces in fact
look at that night every black piece is
attacking I got I got everything going
on here okay and my bishops attacking
his bishop he never he never moved his
rook he never moved his ancient G pawns
and tried to make me all he did was
defend no okay and so that was one of my
favorite games because I won and I got
to sacrifice a bishop and a queen
usually I sacrificed nothing because
then I'm down pieces okay but there's
something more important than a bishop
in a queen checkmate the King if you can
check make your opponent you can give up
everything you want as long as you
checkmate them and every move I tried to
move some other piece into the attack
because if I'm attacking in with three
four five six pieces that's difficult
for him to defend from attacking with
one piece he just stops the one piece
but I had too many pieces near his King
so he couldn't defend and he played too
many passive moves in the early middle
game so in this position which is a
normal position King be one that's not
attacking me f3 that's not attacking me
Queen f2 that's not attacking me and
probably White's already losing I think
blackberry has a winning position
because I'm going to attack attack
attack and he never attacked me at all
and one of my favorite things to do when
I'm attacking a King is to get a piece
on the open file without moving it
usually you move your work to the open
file but the a file was open and I
didn't move my rug so I got a free open
file was his work on an open file now
horrible ok so that was one of my
the computer said I played well and I
got to attack his King he didn't attack
my King so I wasn't worried like oh no
I'm gonna get made it he was worried he
was going to get made it so there's some
positions like this when two
supercomputers are playing and it says
it's equal because it doesn't see a
checkmate but when sooo humans are
playing and you're attacking attacking
attacking and your opponent's not
attacking the the one who's attacking is
going to win a lot of times when you
have three four or five pieces attacking
and your opponent's like no that's
because you sacrifice the material
you're down a rook or you're down a
knight and you're hoping to give checked
me I didn't sacrifice anything and I was
attacking the whole game so that was fun
ths is fun except for all the noise
people were making during the game
outside the game luckily you guys
weren't there so wasn't you well what
maybe was here I think it was you at
home if you live in Atlanta it was you
okay
so that was the lecture on the opposite
side castling checkmate rawr game which
you missed somehow I get it but you can
watch it in fast motion see there you go
it's sort of like a mini Yacoubian I'll
show the game again I'm really fast
you